the editor is joining me on stage of
this afternoon come from both fiction
and documentary film on my far right is
una [ __ ] nila who's been nominated for
the missing next to her is Ben Stark who
edited tsunami survivors stories then we
have young miles and Sherlock and the
episode he was nominated for is the last
in the third series his last vow then
Jake Martin Grayson Perry who are you
nominated for episode 1 and finally
Rupert Houseman who is the editor on
life and death row episode 1 execution
just to start with a couple of general
questions I'm curious about this stage
at which you became involved in these
projects and perhaps you need we could
start with you just talking a little bit
about when you actually like to be
involved how early in the process you
actually like to be involved and your
actual involvement in the missing well I
got involved in the missing whenever
their scripts were written the director
was obscene and crewing up and I got the
call her for scripts written and Jack
and Harry Williams of the brilliant
writers so they were still writing to
the Final Four so I got the four scripts
while I was traveling to Austria read it
on my iPhone and in HD did my skype
interview and was very eager to work
with the guys and to work with Tom
shanklin to the director and then
obviously a very different project
totally different project I met up with
Colonel MacFarland the director when we
need the film was going to be made and
had a very long list of possible
contributors to it and they're kind of
stories and we had quite a long
conversation over several coffees about
what balance we would like to try to
have so that it wasn't a purely quite
depressing film that was more trying to
harness the wonder of people and the
diversity of the experience and how you
can go do something
as random and horrific as that and come
out all right at the other end was very
important to both of us it's again that
the episode so you've been nominated for
I found very interesting because I think
the whole trajectory of Sherlock has
been this propulsive momentum of
constantly transforming this character
this central character that everyone
until the TV series came along felt they
knew and this more than many of the
other episodes really felt like there
was in essence that that they really
wanted to keep changing I was invited to
the read-through on the way to the
read-through it was I mean it you could
tell the script was brilliant laree
through me just to get all the actors
they're really in it just because came
alive at the table yes or hairs on the
back your name so going to end up and
Sherlock had a certain style so when
Nick how in the director film it was so
many things that are already in place so
his strength was entirely you know it
it's from from its script it just goes
to show that good script is way long way
it is a deep what a case of all time
when Jake how early were you involved in
a sort of development of a Grayson Perry
program I'm Chris Perry I work with Neil
crumby the director for about 10 years
so I've worked in voters films and I did
the previous series of Grayson Perry and
I think as soon as you finish that he
was talking about what the next serious
is going to be so it was an ongoing
conversation really but what was going
to be and then we just started eating
really that's neat well I think it's
different it is different mean like next
week I saw a job I have even met the
director so and Rupert life and death
row which what I find quite fascinating
about it and cure for you to talk about
is that it is a program that's covering
a very sort of well-worn area of death
row in the US but manages to always stop
shorts around of actually taking a stand
and instead leaves everything open for
the audience and could you talk a little
bit about the conversations you had with
the director
yes I mean when I died where we've been
Anthony before anyway so that's why when
they were talking about we were out
laughs when we finished 77 we've got in
discussions about what we would like to
do next and Ben was approached to do
love love death row by column barn we
thought that'd be a nice thing to do you
know a good thing to do and actually
because it's well trodden that's what
made it interesting because mostly what
you get with that subject matter is
liberal documentary being made you know
Zod because it's just terrible everyone
knows is awful but to try and tell the
counter-argument and make a balanced
film is a much more interesting
challenge to try and frame it in that
way I mean been affirmed for the entire
year in Texas 19 people were executed
over that year and he filmed loads of
them and so so when we first started
making it was going to be a year in the
life of Texas and thinking and it was it
was overwhelming loss of footage quite
bleak but there were two stories which
felt they were always going to be quite
strong bedfellows and there they were
banded up being the two we put together
for the for the hour in the end now with
each of the nominated program from
curious about that was this specific
moment of a challenge that you you face
them that when you look back on the
episode of the documentary you kind of
think yeah I managed to sort of crack
that up stay with you you got well it
was it was just that balance also the
idea of trying to play things
dramatically and not feeling that you're
crossing the line you know is you know
because again that was a balance is
constantly wrestle to try and sort of
push things as far as we can push them
without being grotesque you know because
it's a it's there's so much heat inside
some of those rushes just watching some
of that stuff these people are going
through horrendous experiences I mean I
mean been talked about sort of you know
having two terrible days filming he had
to the first time he met both Anthony
Haines and Richard Coeur average acog
was on the day of their the day before
their execution so can imagine sitting
there setting up only often staring into
the eyes of people who are
24 hours later probably going to be dead
and that's an extraordinary thing to
witness and you know docking Ducks are
brilliant at doing this and especially
cuz we use an interior on in that so we
all looked into the eyes of these people
they conveyed all these emotions
instantaneously to us and it's quite an
experience as an editor to see some of
that stuff and it does it you know it
affects all of us I think we sort of
look at rushes and we get me to bits
when we soak it up and then we want to
convey that straight away I think what
was good about that what was the bit
that made me really made me go home or
energy is that too much is that the
thing I have to remove now because if I
leave that bit in it pushes us over the
edge and then the nominees that these
two films I think sort of have something
in common than you are dealing with
terrible true life and death situation
and it did it did as you were working
with the material was the discussions
over what you can can't show and the
challenges in there were lots of
discussions not let not really about
what we can and can't show about what we
did or didn't want to show we weren't
there wasn't a voice from above which
rubbers to be honest kind of expecting
they might have been but that but there
wasn't in the the people that were
speaking to us they were voluntarily
speaking to us they wanted for whatever
cathartic reasons to share this very
intimate part of their lives with us and
whether larger audience and they trusted
us to do that with the archive it's
completely different and quarter of a
million people died in this it in the
tsunami and we have hundreds of hours of
archive blot of what would traditionally
be called the best archive is from
people that didn't survive and then
you've got to be aware that is that
someone's family that's the last moments
of this existence on the other you know
and that's where those conversations
come up you want to highlight that you
want to feel the random
nature of a beautiful Christmas suddenly
turning into a kind of defining moment
of your life or or or end of life at the
same time with just making a film we're
not there there's actually their lives
and where those lines of where those
lines are are very hard to interpret it
that they're there something you have to
feel in the moment sometimes there are
moments which are you would immediately
say that's a bit over the line but
actually in the context of the film you
can go there and it brings it all home
to all of us with the missing it's quite
fascinating with it is for many people
it's extremely sensitive subject yeah
that's slightly more abstract in the
public consciousness and I'm curious
about the discussions that you have
intended that sort of challenges that
you felt you faced a bag approaching
what's essentially thriller material
yeah yeah but some with that sometimes
like what edgy correctly so the script
was like this thriller with a puzzle but
it implicit in that was the loss of a
child so although what Rupert and banner
doing is very real we still had a moral
responsibility although it's a fiction
not be gratuitous in you cashing in on
this child going missing so for instance
episode three at the end of episode
three when when James Nesbitt comes in
and they find the clip of the child
buying at the window I mean that was
very that was discussed by yourself we
don't over egg this because next fact
its inherent in the materials we didn't
have to put music on our you didn't have
to over emotionalize the whole thing
because it was already there so we
really did feel a moral responsibility
because the audience at home of course
get involved in the fiction and they
begin to live through these characters
and identify that with them as much as
if you watch documentary and then become
invested in this child so we did we
really wanted to thread with caution and
the times we held back on ycharts
deliberately are on the back of
somebody's head so was not to be in
their face at
cycling to use the term emotional parag
raphy which I'm I was servicing more as
a moral responsibility that we were
keeping you know back we didn't want to
be in big big close ups if it was
something very important happening on
sunscreen so we did we did try and
thread with caution and with respect to
the subject because it's every family's
worst nightmare Jake um what a fun
fascination with Grayson Perry is the
and it's did a clever element of what
one might perceive to be a mainstream
entertainment is that Grayson Perry
deals with incredibly tricky topics and
people's lives whether it's gender
change or changing religion but to these
people a huge personal crisis and I
found it fascinating watching the
nominated episode the you managed to
perfectly get the balance between this
exuberant character this host this guide
who's taking us through these characters
lives but also never being so
overwhelming that it kind of dominates
the stories the personal stories of
these people yeah I think that's really
down to grace and he's quite
extraordinary uhm Greyson does he
listens he really really listens to
people worried when he saw against them
and that's a ground very unusually would
be neither i would talk about it he
really really listens even when Neil and
I would not particularly find a
conversation that interesting but grace
enters absorbs and he will pick
something from that conversation that we
might not tank had been that relevant
but that was it that was it for him
actually that was the bit that made the
whole moments were saying I think I
struggles with that were kind of make
these individuals stories kind of
universal feel like there were not
really about just a one single person's
kind of change but they actually had a
relevance to everybody that I reflected
back home like Jazz's story is well
things that his original was jesting is
Alexandra now but the the kind of sex
change that did it's everybody sexual
journey it's not just his
violin search for identity is everybody
search and soon swans forth and that was
our big thing really yeah and a
different challenge that I felt when I
was watching sherlock and and something
the reason I think it's such a huge
success is balancing the clever
cleverness all of what students been
doing with this incredibly strong
emotional core to the series and I felt
with this episode you said earlier about
being bold yeah the sequence that
follows Sherlock being shot it's
absolutely astonishing basic spends ten
minutes in my own palace yeah yeah the
trick who filming is it and hey I feel
like I'm making popcorn compared to
these guys by the way making everybody
laugh you're making everybody cried but
we however did make people cry oh shut
up as well but yeah I think that the
funnel Sherlock is is the inner is this
it's like the you never the show up the
license to sort of go anyway you are I
curry and some mind Palace things
preserved was a sword concept amenia
Nick obviously you know shop them poured
lots of rushes towards me but I co had a
pretty pretty kind of a lot of freedom
to play with her it's good fun but like
going to the emotional level of it I
think we're Stevens really brilliant
their say in his writing you know he'll
thought but it seemed very early in the
film where he sort of said you know I've
got a project for you it's going to lead
to your death you know and it's all
somewhere in Eastern Europe I wanted to
give me the job you know me and he
buries that little nugget of information
then towards the very end of the film
when he's being taken away for murder
and he say goodbye to Watson he says
what were you doing where are you going
I'm going to go do a little job in
Eastern Europe so you know you've
traveled up with that emotion what was
really brilliant waters Bennett it went
well I'll give you a performance work
wry i'll give you one we're alone so we
have both and it is interesting because
it's the first time for me as an editor
which i learned
it's actually if you don't have the
character cry them more like the
audience will cry which is kind of all
these guys are talking about what they
show in probably documentaries it for me
it's very different but but that kind of
learning curve that emotional level is
contained you know by the storytelling
from all the new authors as happens so
much earlier in the film it's not in
your faith on that note I think we do
have to draw to a close very best of
luck to all of you tomorrow night please
join me in thanking I guess
you